do you remember where you were sep
tember 11 2001 I was in Kyla I was home
yes and how did you feel that day what
was the what was the mood like in Cairo
I don't know it's it's you know when you
feel it sir it's not real you when you
feel it's a movie this happening and
read this is what the what was the
modern kyle i believe so very much
nobody could believe himself that it's
happening on TV and railings and the two
buildings are broken of course it was
very bad to to be seen in it was very
bad to happen was very bad to to lose
these souls because any one of them on
any one of the people that we lost could
be a great resource for Humanity some
any one of the humanity can be at
leisure but it's not favorably to lose
someone and it's with this instance was
very bad how have you seen people change
both in Cairo and in the US maybe maybe
people just started to to look at the
other side maybe maybe of course i would
i would love this to happen through a
positive thing not throw a bad thing
like but you never know you can create
life from death you can create that from
life it's up to you and I believe that
especially when I believe that the West
we know the worst more than the worst
about us this is this is what I believe
and I know that maybe the we started to
sort it and to have a desire to know an
answer about the question that why do
they hate us is why many people came to
our region to ask this question to
search why do they hit us why this was
the men and simply we don't eat at all
we don't hate you at all simply love
needs love I know every one of us wants
to be loved but if he you want me to
love you show me the first as simpler
than this it's very very easy
you